i think it's time for some paterone
questioning what's up [ __ ] army my
name is dylan from omaha nebraska what a
boy new to the army knew the whole
podcast thing but i've been following
akash and andrew on stand up for a while
and i just wanted to come in hot and say
[ __ ] murky gag why
i mean get out your feelings i was
diagnosed with lymphoma
and
you guys really make everyone see the
light and even impending doom the first
thing i thought is am i gonna need a
neck abortion
do i smell like a cleveland mother's
thyroid problem
and before you all get soft on me
just know cancer brings [ __ ] i'll be
the fault in all these hoe stars
one of the real questions
is
do you guys have any bits that just live
in your mind rent free i was like i got
a dave chappelle he's one of my goats
you know i got my mount rushmore and uh
he has a skit from killing him softly i
think where he talks about a baby on the
corner selling crack and i can almost
see dave
like do this whole skit hand movements
everything and i think it influences how
i make jokes and i just wondered if any
of you guys had any bits like that just
stuck up there anyways love you guys and
for real
i'll be high don't be [ __ ] about it
keep doing your thing blood army
all right respect alan
i never said
do you say do you do you apologize what
did i say you should apologize
everybody listen got cancer apparently
okay i didn't realize how many people we
were affecting that we hang out with
people tuesday thursday friday yeah
we're going to connect and we're going
to help people okay that's what's up why
did you think about that before when you
were sad no i just [ __ ]
you apologize for your watching inside
out every single time hit me up what was
he doing so you guys
came out there
also we gotta look at his ceiling that
should have mad [ __ ] stains on it
you could be breathing in some asbestos
especially
i need you to look into that darling
yeah you're a [ __ ] real one mark you
need to apologize to all the people that
really appreciate this podcast and all
the good that you're doing
i'm sorry bro you didn't realize how you
affected the world my bad anyone else
that's full of cancer out there my bad
all right i love you guys i respect you
also darling i just want to let you know
um last [ __ ] that had cancer to
listen to the podcast beat that [ __ ] oh
the precedent has been insane
don't stop working every single day
don't stop working every single day
don't take it easy but yeah but if steve
jobs listen to this podcast oh
definitely
if he was trying to yoga that [ __ ] out
of his system that's not how you do it
you gotta laugh at it what is laughter
what is it the best medicine
[Music]
don't listen to that you go listen do
what them doctors tell you to do okay
two two medicines double medication
their medicine and
then
yeah yeah yeah don't listen to the
catholic doctor bro
[ __ ] didn't even believe the
sun was in the middle giving you
prostate exams for no reason they did
they said they both
you don't think that works
it probably made me feel a little better
yeah feel a little bit that's why mark
always says he's not sick he started
getting molested by these cats
i'm not saying i promise
don't do it again
do you have a bit that lives in your
head that another oh i forgot the
question that's right yeah yeah the the
bit that oh god i mean there's a bunch
of patrice ones chris rock ones there's
a couple that come to mind eddie half
eddie
yeah and then uh chris rock [ __ ]
payments
both of those once you get married both
those bits start playing over and over
again in your mind dude chris rock
there's like just so many eddie murphy
the story yeah the goonie gugu
uh just him acting out his dad yeah they
took a [ __ ] eddie yeah they took a dog
took a [ __ ] eddie yeah i mean there's so
many patrice yeah dude there's a bunch
those bits just come to you all the time
because i think about the truth behind
like how good those bits were and ahead
of their time
those two with half and then chris rock
talking about you know i'm accustomed to
this i'm accustomed to that the women go
in there and get half the money's like i
would love to see a man be like yo you
want to check this out yeah yeah i'm
accustomed to [ __ ] her four times a
week yeah she had the money but i said
[ __ ] payments
so good yeah chris rock and tosh are the
two hours oh yeah
all of them literally all the time
people talk about war and i'm like yeah
let's just do it on our home home yeah
home turf wake up in the morning have a
delicious breakfast drive to war yeah
yeah yeah i think about all the time in
nebraska nobody needs that horrible
state yeah
i was there for a week i was waiting for
a tornado to take me anywhere
it was like award shows like they were
like oh i can't believe i got this it's
like you had an aisle seat [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah
i've never seen someone win an award and
they climb out of the [ __ ] balcony
oh dude he had some joke about nebraska
how is there a meth problem who wants to
stay awake longer
america's the best oh yeah have you ever
seen fiji yeah yeah yeah
you got so many i remember right when
the dark knight came out he got on stage
at the improv and the first thing he
said he goes i can't believe batman
killed heath ledger can you believe that
batman killed he's ledger and it was
just such a wild way to start a set and
then he went in just killed for 25
minutes straight dude he's he's got
classics dude yeah
yeah that special is just [ __ ]
oh yeah it's great what is that special
uh completely serious or fully serious
true stories i made up yeah both are
great yeah uh dude people pleaser was
the last one yeah i didn't see the last
one yeah as far but he's just phenomenal
yeah okay next one so check those out my
brother what's up and best of luck with
everything we ride with you from dc
um first up i want to say congrats to
andrew
infamous 2 was lit i caught it when you
were in dc that [ __ ] was amazing thank
you brother um side note mark was
actually funny
[Music]
i can't wait until the special drops
uh my question for you this week is
um
what would you think will be liberal cox
response
if we find a female a black female trump
and also do you think she would be worse
than the actual trump oh
i mean that's candice right candace
candace and everybody's terrified of her
people don't really go with candace yeah
i don't know if you can call her black
female trump though talk to me because
trump is like funny
like candace is not funny she's like
researched and like nuanced yeah she
feels like a political operative
whereas like trump was just like saying
crazy [ __ ] he was funny yeah just a
lightning rod it's like cardi b
if cardi was conservative yeah she's
just liberal but if cardi was
conservative it'd be kind of fun i ain't
trying to pay no taxes
like like it kind of would be digestible
war
yeah well
mike pence isn't going to be uh vp next
time for that run so she could be a good
fee to trump oh [ __ ] you know trump's vp
pick will be interesting yeah
if he wins a primary which i think he
will if he even goes for it you think
he's gonna go for it yes santas or him
so let's see that
but you think republicans rock with her
though
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
even if they don't he's just going to
create so much attention
republicans fall in line
yeah okay go hey guys it's your boy tage
oh yeah first of all dove
proud of you for choosing to go from the
truffle to the truffle butter oh second
if you guys need some
diversity on your flag football team for
the patreon let your boy know i was uh
not just one but two but three-time city
champion for my as a captain on my flag
team
so if you need some brown spice in the
mix hit your boy up
now for my hypothetical say the only way
you could be funny is that you had to be
morbidly obese so bmi is over 40. for
you guys it's probably being over 300
pounds would you guys gain the weight
or would you guys go for more leaner
pastures
now finally when i address hoss
my guy's always asking for all this beef
and all this other stuff
you know what no one's answering him so
i think he really should stick to like a
vegan diet
you know he already got that here
i think this guy wants that nagasaki
come on
until next time
get morbidly obese
they're morbidly obese bmi get your bmi
up to 60. go away
nah
nah i'm it's crazy we got that video we
set up the video yeah yeah yeah we got
to play that [ __ ] yeah someone was
glistening on yeah he was swag
you got the
the hardest punches bro that
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] crushed
crush toss right there
you might as well be vegan
oh god love you tash
what was this question i remember his
question if you could the only way you
could be funny is if you're hell no i'm
not being over thank you bro thank you
no you lose your job who gives a [ __ ]
i'll get another job
i'll figure some [ __ ] out and [ __ ] all
that you want to be 300 pounds i'm not
trying to go out
of here
most people in america do that every day
they just are super fat yeah i wouldn't
be them yeah yeah yeah yeah
most people you would disdain that dude
i remember it it took ralph he made like
eight minutes to get on stage one time
and i was like this is rough dog get out
of here
obese mark
morbidly obese you die because of fat oh
he said 300 pounds no he said morbidly
obese maybe for akash that's 300 pounds
yeah for me that might not be more
no
can i lose it hold up
no if you lose you lose you're funny so
my funny is tied to i mean that would
suck not being funny yeah it would suck
would you just be like a little fat to
be a little funny yes
oh yes
i'd find the limit of like how funny i
needed to be yeah and then just stay
over there oh god what a horrible
question
everything especially you just get
balloon up
oh could i could i do the opposite of a
fighter
yeah so like i balloon up oh for like a
year for the specials cut for three and
then cut yeah
but then you cut and you're like not
funny life is nothing without humor oh
this is i don't even like that go right
inside out
i don't want to hear these things
anymore go chris stop it i don't want to
think about it
uh it's chris
i don't have any questions for this week
but
just from the comment of house last week
i just want to say of course that carl
looking boy wants beef
he's lucky
i'm hindu
otherwise he would make for a good
medium rare
what's he coming
with heat on my board
[Laughter]
i would rather be [ __ ] hopies
archives really the funniest brown
community
he really is bro you did it you done
accomplished it i caught it
on a curve doug it's a rare for indians
but you got to grade me on a curve oh
[ __ ] what's up keep playing though this
[ __ ] is hilarious really needs a speech
therapist oh god tonight isn't funny
what the [ __ ]
seriously right let me ah let me ask you
a question how do you pronounce ask
anyway
what's going on
let's go chris
let's go
let's go son chris is a beast that's my
boy right there yo
come on yo
come on come on
could you be funny like that
can you be playing like that
because if you do that
you can do that i'm just skinny again
cause we out here dying right now
we are here [ __ ]
hey hey hey hey [ __ ] y'all
yeah he's lucky i mean i might have went
medium rare on that ass bro
son of a
[ __ ] we're stopping the podcast on
that right there oh my gosh you guys
ain't that senseless you're speechless
that's [ __ ]
nobody's ever gonna laugh that hard ever
again that's the funniest thing that can
ever happen
he's lucky gonna beef him
look at him cow looking boy
got beef
making medium rare
mate oh man
just say one nice thing to chris she's
probably listening right now i said
chris is the [ __ ] man i'd rather be
that funny
nothing funnier than chris chris got to
do the intro to every single podcast he
doesn't have a long beat right now
what's up everybody welcome to fragrance
2.
welcome to fragrance 2.
okay
water cooler commentary for your sports
[Laughter]
mark
is [ __ ] causing all this humor and
laughter dude dallin is dying right now
bro
no no no he's a little better
he's getting better he's literally
healed dallin bro
he [ __ ] heals that we do dale just
yanked out them dialysis tubes
is it dialysis
what is it chemotherapy
chemo chemo
chemotherapy dialysis is your kidneys
diabetic oh my bad i want first of all i
want to know um what filter chris was
using to shoot that video son
what do you mean like coffee filter
no like
it looked
mid blast
like it looked like the nuke got dropped
but
you know that white that takes over oh
yeah that's what i just stayed there
yeah the shock wave yeah [ __ ]
krish
do you know what i'm saying chris is the
beast miles chill out you know what i'm
saying
turn you into some medium rare right
mom might turn you medium rare
chris you're the [ __ ] man bruh
you ever split them [ __ ] lips
all right yo peace love we see you next
week patrione what up people you just
watched a clip from our weekly patreon
episode you can support the flagrancy
you can support this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
alright peace